security to us as italy is to see
talibs to guarantee human rights and
human freedoms women's rights and
children rights first of all
and international organizations should
have access
to provide humanitarian relief because
afghan people
need humanitarian relief
and of course our international
community should provide this relief and
this country should not become
a refuge for terrorism and we should
also think
about how we can
manage migration flows from afghanistan
outgoing migration flows and we talked
about this with minister lavrov and i
said that
we need to divide our approaches we need
to work globally and this is the only
way to talk to have a dialect with the
new authorities and kabul and we as
italy keeping in mind that we are
cheering the g20
we are ready to engage in deep
discussions regarding afghanistan with
the minister lavrov we talked the main
topics of the g20 agenda healthcare
climate
trade and we hope that
we will continue our cooperation
and we will cooperate with russia work
with russia
when we are chairing the g20 to
face the global challenges and we have
also talked about the mediterranean
region problems starting with libya and
the cooperation with moscow in this
regard plays a central role for us and i
emphasized in our conversation with mr
lavrov that this cooperation is very
important for us and it is very
important for the international
community to stay engaged in a dialogue
inside libya and to continue and it
continued to work
under the u.n ages that are some kind of
facilitators
to
we need to coordinate our efforts and we
have emphasized the necessity to
withdraw
foreign troops
and foreign
militants from libya
and we also want to emphasize our
bilateral traditional historical ties
ties between our nations and that's
what we were guided with when we adopted
the roadmap of consultation to talk
about the most important international
political matters and we are ready to
work together to
organize our efforts to fight the
current virus pandemic so that we could
guarantee
that
resolving this crisis overcoming the
pandemic could allow us to resume our
economic activities and we have a lot of
economic ties technical ties scientific
ties that unite
our countries our civil societies our
entrepreneurs and our academicians our
scientists in the scientific field at
the same time we think that friends
should be sincere and frank talking with
each other and we should be frank when
we talk about matters where we have
disagreements with that's why i
reiterated once again we talked about
our concerns regarding alexey navalny
case and i said that in our opinion
same criteria should be applied when
dealing with him that would correspond
to the fundamental human rights
these are criteria that should be
applied and i said that
we should
put the minsk package of measures in the
spotlights when resolving the ukrainian
crisis and to work also in normandy
format and trilateral format and
implementation of the minsk agreements
will allow
to resume relations between the eu and
russia
in the topics that are of interest for
both sides like climate change and
healthcare and in the future we will
have to have this approach we need to
deal with it globally and it would allow
us to reach our goals thank you for your
attention
ladies and gentlemen we have concluded
our talks in rome in the morning i met
the chairman of the council of ministers
mario draghi and i have just concluded
the
detailed com consultations with the
minister of foreign affairs luigi demaio
italy is one of the leading countries
that we are engaged with the trade
cooperation and investment cooperation
the pandemic situation of course
slowed down our cooperation last year
the trade turnover decreased but in the
first half of the current year
has increased again
by 30 percent
and
russian italian council for economic
industrial currency financial
cooperation played an important role it
shared by luigi maya on italian part and
it's shared by denise mantur mantrov
on our behalf we talked about future
contexts at different at various levels
we expressed our satisfaction with the
fact that this year in july
in yekaterinburg
at the international exhibition called
inaprom
the very first european nation to become
a partner
was italy and the minister of economic
development mr torchetti was the head of
the delegation that visited the
exhibition and we highly
appraised the work that the russian
italian committee of entrepreneurs is
doing and involved with we also talked
about positive outcomes of the
participation of the italian business
delegation and saint petersburg economic
forum that took place early in june this
year and where a number of important
commercial contracts were signed
we highly appreciate and we strive to
develop humanitarian cultural ties
educational exchange we would like to
put more impetus in context between
youth learning languages of our
countries and we talked about
how
the museum here
cross cultural year is being implemented
there are a number of projects including
events that will be organized in italy
to
celebrate
200 years anniversary of federer
dostoyevsky
and we have reaffirmed our support for
the
civil society dialogue for and my
counterpart mentioned importance of
concerted efforts in fighting curbing
the pandemic in april of this year we
have signed memorandum of
cooperation between the gamalie
institute research institute russian
direct
investment fund
and the infection disease institute
named after lazarus palinzani
this is the agreement
that was uh simulated by the coronavirus
pandemic situation but we laid the
groundwork for systemic cooperation in
the long term and i'm confident that it
will be mutually beneficial we hope that
step by step the restrictions pandemic
restrictions will be lifted and we will
be able to resume the travel arrangement
for the citizens of our country russian
government one month ago made a decision
to resume regular flights to italy and
this allows italian citizens to enter
our country
under the same conditions as before as
for the international agenda we talk
about the prospects of our cooperation
in anti-terrorist activities and
anti-criminal activities
we have made a headway we have bilateral
mechanisms we have channels of
collaboration
under the u.n ages
efforts and of course
in light of the italy chairing the g20
group we talked a lot about this
organization and working in this
organization and this format is more
adequate than narrower groups and it
better reflects the multi-polar
realities and obviously afghanistan
took a special place in our
conversation
we condemn the terrorist acts we mourn
with the families of those who were
killed during this terrorist act and of
course we
see it as an additional
impetus to
expedite the efforts to help afghans for
them to organize without
any obstacles the
new inclusive government with the
participation of all the main political
forces of the country and of course we
talked
when we talked about the consequences of
the current situation in uh broader
light about migrants about refugees
about asylum seekers our western
counterparts
they always want to
work together to have concerted efforts
to look for answers together and i've
already answered this question a number
of days ago but we should learn our
lessons after iraq after libya and now
after afghanistan these attempts to
impose
someone else's values on other nations
are very dangerous
and i hope that the third
time they will draw these consequences
and the politicians they will remember
they will learn this lessons when they
will think about the future
activities and uh strange countries for
us it's very important to ensure
security of our southern borders of our
allies in central asia
it has been already on the agenda of the
summit that took place online
cstl summit
and
and person summit will take place in
mid-september and at the same time one
day prior or one day later after csto
summit there will be seo summit i have
no doubt that
everything that comes from afghanistan
provoked first of all
this illegal migrants flows provoked by
the events in afghanistan there will be
in the center of attention of our
leaders discussions and they will also
talk about how we can help
afghans to provide stability and normal
functioning of all the agencies of the
government we also talked about the
situation in europe we shared our
assessment of the
actions by the leaders of the european
union that
still keep
anti-russian destructive sentiment
under the impact of a certain
russophobic group
um persephobic minority we also talked
about the situation in ukraine we share
the position that minsk agreements means
package of measures must be implemented
we shared this position and we gave
clear examples how the new ukrainian
legislation is basically forbidding
kiev authorities or other facilitators
to implement what is stipulated and
means agreements so the situation is
quite difficult and i really hope that
all our european colleagues that are
sincerely interested in seeing the
situation in ukraine normalized and
resolved they will use their
influence on the kiev regime
and we also talked about lieben about
other
issues in the mediterranean in north
africa
there are not a lot of things that we
can
do positive but we share the position
regarding libyan settlement we are
talking about
gradual and synchronized withdrawal of
foreign troops from the country and we
support the priority of helping
the country to have comprehensive
elections my count report talked about
navalny mentioned navalny and once again
i recommended him and i suggest everyone
who really wants to
make this situation clear to read the
minutes of the bundestag meeting when
a german government replied to
an answer to one of the bundestag
members regarding the situation with the
so-called poisoning
i have no doubt absolutely no doubt that
any person unbiased person who will read
these texts will draw conclusions
about
the
bigger part of this problem is keep is
kept in secret for whatever reason and
we would
like to know why too and recently in
kiev there was an event
called the crimea platform summit and in
this regard our retailing country parts
participated in this event and we talked
about our assessment of this
senseless inane idea and it just
increased the tension where we need to
admit the current realities existing
realities and the reality is that
republic of crimea and the city of
sevastopol are part of the russian
federation according to the
open vote of the people who live there
and in general we talked
in detail
and quite productively i invited luigi
demaio to
pay a visit to the russian federation
hopefully we will continue our dialogue
and also regarding the matters that
the president of russian prime minister
of the italian republic discussed over
the film thank you for your attention
is this it
thank you thank you very much and now we
are going to have questions ansi agency
please
good afternoon minister demaio welcome
minister lavrov i've got the question
for minister di mai what is this
situation now in afghanistan because now
we can see that the uk
germany friends are concluding their
operations on evacuating people when
will the last italian planes take off
from there and next question about the
g20
how do you prepare
for this summit and obviously you should
have discussed it with minister lavrov
what could be
russia's input in this preparation
because
russia is has some kind of communication
channel with the taliban one way or
another i would like to say briefly that
the afghanistan crisis as you are well
aware it's a very complicated issue very
dramatic issue and there are no simple
answers to this question we have a moral
duty not to turn our back
to afghan people and italy invested a
lot to afghanistan
and
we
the
country that is sharing in g20 group we
would like to reach global international
consensus regarding key items of the
strategy that we can use in the afghan
crisis
and because there is some insecurity
regarding the future of the country and
i think g20 could become a great
platform to coordinate efforts to manage
this crisis in concerted manner and we
are talking about the divided approach
we need to separate the approach and we
need also to work together with the
countries that are going to suffer most
from the migration from afghanistan and
we talked with minister lavrov and
neighboring country's country suggesting
to afghanistan and obviously
this extraordinary g20 summit could
allow us to
coordinate
international efforts these five
priorities
that i've mentioned and it would allow
us to consolidate the
political position of this forum and
that's why we would like to
have this extraordinary g20 meeting
to talk about the topic of afghanistan
so that we could use this inclusive
format
to
find out our common goals
and as for the situation on the ground i
would like to give you some figures
these days so
us and the fans ministry we evacuated
all italian nationals from the countries
all those italian nationals who wanted
to return from afghanistan they were
given this opportunity and they used it
and about 400.
4 900 afghan nationals were also
evacuated
and
we did it in the foreign ministry did it
in cooperation with defense ministry and
with our embassy in kabul
and in the next few hours the last plane
last italian plane is going to take off
and they're going to be consulate tamaza
claudi will be on board and an
ambassador ponte corvo and all the
military personnel all
the carabineri
that were ensuring the safety of the
evacuation operations i would like to
thank all of them
so that's what is happening
there and the last plane
will have
on board those people who made it
possible who made it possible to
evacuate almost 5 000 people from
afghanistan
a girl talked about
russia what should we do should we
involve
we've been involved with the taliban or
something we were involved in a dialogue
with everyone for
many years now and under moscow format
that has all the country in the region
and also the united states china in
india of course in pakistan they also
participate in this format and we also
were engaged in a dialogue with taliban
in the extended troika format
russia the united states china and
pakistan and we were engaged in this
dialogue until recently
we had conversations and negotiations in
the qatar capital doha and we saw the
trend of slowing down the negotiations
and when you don't achieve results at
the negotiation table then hostilities
could resume and that's exactly what
happened but once again we were ready to
support the agreements that americans
had with the taliban and unfortunately
regrettably
they were not implemented
and i guess
not only because the taliban was against
it as for the future formats performance
of the future work we talked with mario
draghi with the prime minister and we
talked with luigi de mayo too in a lot
of detail
we would like to understand what role
our friends
so how they see g20 what added value
will be given
using this mechanism
and we were promised to
give
a paper
where everything will be explained luigi
has just mentioned that there are five
principles that must be implemented that
he listed
some time before but if i remember it
right the counter-terrorism efforts are
priority number five and first four
items are different i think we are going
to have different priorities and i said
that the main thing for us is to ensure
safety of our allies in the south
along the southern borders of the
russian federation
countries that have
shared borders with afghanistan and what
luigi emphasized the need for an
inclusive format it's an important thing
too and i mentioned five central asian
countries that are not part of the g20
pakistan is not in the g20 iran is not
in the g20 and
without them it will be hard to have a
full-fledged conversation
comprehensive conversation and our
counterparts
counterparts promise to think about the
forms that could be really useful and we
are going to be engaged with the afghan
matters and with the
consequences of what happened under the
csto and seo
and we will be ready to consider
actual suggestions and proposals from
the talent side what part could g20 play
in all these efforts
thank you
we've got a question from azvest here
channel
recently a lot has been said about the
situation in afghanistan i think there
is
some consensus regarding uh the need for
concerted efforts not to make
afghanistan a hotbed of the
international terrorism and
did you manage to come up with some
concerted efforts during these
negotiations and how russia will react
to new threats that happen every day
like the terrorist attack that has just
happened and the second question
for
mr lavrov there is an interesting
correlation that the san marino
nationals who are mostly vaccinated with
the russian vaccine sputnik v
they can enter italy without any
restrictions but russian nationals who
are also vaccinated by the
putting
they are forbidden from entering don't
you see it is a double standard policy
and have you talked with your italian
counterpart
what could be the condition to resume
the tourism
between russia and italy and if mr
demaio could comment one of this
question we would appreciate it a lot
as for what are our priorities in
afghanistan in this new situation i have
just talked about it in a lot of detail
so we will coordinate our efforts with
our allies with our strategic partners
under csto and seo organizations we are
ready to
work together with all other countries
that could facilitate the normalization
and stabilization of the situation in
afghanistan making emphasis on ensuring
safety and security because everything
else is going to be our priorities
number two and so on as for san marino i
asked luigi demaio
so
what is the reason of this uh
privileged position for san marino in
comparison with russian nationals
because
both of them are vaccinated with the
same vaccine
and as for the resumption of tourism yes
we hope that as soon as the situation
with the mutual recognition of vaccines
is resolved this the tourism will resume
for a month now we have reinstated
direct flights to italy and italians who
come to russia using these flights using
these planes
they can enter our country with no
restrictions according to their plans
whatever plans they have
when they visit our country yes the vast
majority of the countries of the eu the
width for the signal from the european
medicines agency
but
it is well known that the final
decisions will be made by
national
regulation agencies like it's been done
in hungary so they domestically
registered the sputnik v vaccine and we
have an agreement about the mutual
recognition of the vaccines with the
vaccine that we use in russia and the
vaccines that they use in hungary so
actually the
it's up to the national governments to
make these decisions and the european
union well you heard the statements that
were made
the
one can call them constructive and
regard of the russian and chinese
vaccines
i would like to add afghanistan in
respect of this
last subject matter and
regarding afghanistan as well the san
bernardino nationals they will need to
make a third jab
to
get green passport according to the law
that was adopted
just
before august so they should get the
third baxter that is recognized by the
european medicines agency
and italian government
will
wait for the decision by the european
medicine agency and of course there is
also european commission and
they have been talking recently that
there are some countries outside the
european union
if apart from the vaccines
that a person has used this person
nevertheless
can
move around inside the european borders
and we
talking about this now with the
healthcare ministry but currently san
marino nationals
they were given an opportunity to adapt
to
the criterias of the italian green pass
so that
to do that they will need to get a third
job as for afghanistan i completely
shared the principle according to which
the safety and security and this
approach to ensure security first of all
that's truly a priority especially for
the neighboring
countries we have learned throughout the
years and i'm not only talking about
these regions i'm talking about the
global situations how governments
how the european union they learned this
lesson as well that we need to have a
comprehensive approach holistic approach
in fighting terrorism
according to the items that
we have mentioned among our priorities
fighting terrorism
means helping the
people
to for the economy to grow to stop youth
from entering terrorist organizations so
our approach does not exclude
one of the items or
several items all these priorities are
priorities because that's a
comprehensive approach to
fight the problem to face the issue
that
is of uh concern to all of us not to
make afghanistan a threat for all the
neighboring countries
g3
network minister demai you talked about
extraordinary plan
of italy for afghan people
could you talk a little bit about the
tools that you plan to use yes our goal
is to coordinate
all administrative efforts
on the national level and on local level
regional level and we
now working
on creating a control panel
so to say on afghanistan that would
involve all everyone interested starting
from the deans of universities head of
the municipalities representatives of
the civil societies
who would agree
to
be at disposal to help out with the
civil societies which to help children
to help women to help italian families
telling mothers
that were asking me
how
they could
take afghan children into their families
and i think that currently we need to
well as a government we need to
coordinate all these kinds of requests
all these kinds of
efforts all these kinds of sentiments
this readiness
to help
that allow
us to invest in educating afghan youth
that allow us to invest in protecting
afghan women that came here that arrived
here and i said to minister lavrov that
we wouldn't want
to
pave
we don't want the neighboring countries
neighboring to afghanistan to pay for
this crisis and the goal is in helping
and the afghan people to resolve this
problem somehow and
we need to manage the migration flows to
other countries as well
we saw the footage
at the pakistani border
and we are already in contact with the
neighboring countries to help them to
manage these migration flaws
using the u.n
agencies using civil society
representatives and at the same time we
need to work at the european level
to create humanitarian corridors and the
last question please from russia 24.
question from mr lavrov before your
visit
there was a statement allow me to quote
this russian minister wants to
request his telling count report luigi
demaio to be constructive in the matter
of sanctions
so
is this wording true and did you talk at
all about the sanctions no it's not true
we didn't talk about this subject matter
i have a lot of eyewitnesses from our
delegation from the italian delegation
and it shouldn't come as a surprise
because we talked a lot that we are not
going to discuss sanctions with the
countries that
are using the sanctions as a tool
because evidently they have no other
ways to handle their foreign policy and
we are not going to request any
restrictions to be lifted i came to
these three countries hungary austria
and italy by a simple reason because i
was invited and we always appreciate the
chance to be involved in this frank and
mutually
beneficial dialogue mutually
respectful dialogue
thank you
everyone and
good work everyone have a nice day
everyone
you